now to Idaho where there are new details
emerging after police finally arrested a
suspect in the murder of four college
students 28 year old criminology student
Brian coburger was taken into custody
Friday in Pennsylvania the families of
the four victims say the arrest brings
them hope but there are still a lot of
questions Dania Backus has more from
Moscow Idaho
investigators are combing through every
aspect of suspect Brian coburger's life
as they try to piece together a possible
motive in the murders of four University
of Idaho college students we're trying
to build this picture now of
him who he is his history how we got to
this event law enforcement sources say
FBI agents tracked the 28 year olds
movements days leading up to his arrest
at his parents home in eastern
Pennsylvania it's located more than 2500
miles from the house in Moscow Idaho
where coburger is accused of stabbing
Kaley Gonzalez Madison Mogan Zana
kernodle and Ethan Chapin while they
were sleeping on November 13th
Gonzalez's father says their arrest
brings some relief this is the first bit
of joy that we've had in close to seven
weeks we hope they picked the right guy
and that gives us hope and we haven't
had hope for a long time co-burger is a
PhD criminology student at Washington
State University and lived in Pullman
Washington about a 15-minute drive from
the victims
police haven't found a murder weapon or
said if coburger knew the students law
enforcement sources say forensic
analysis allegedly linked him to the
murders
the public defender representing
co-burger in the extradition says about
a month after the murders his client
went on a road trip home to Pennsylvania
with his father that was planned at the
beginning of the semester they were in a
white Hyundai Elantra is the same make
and model of the vehicle spotted near
the scene of the murders the police
department's believes that the person we
have in custody which would be co-worker
is the one who is responsible for these
crimes
in their first statement the family of
Brian coburger said they care deeply for
the four families who have lost children
they also said they are fully
cooperating with police in an attempt to
seek the truth and promote his
presumption of innocence Ed
anyavakis in Idaho Forest thank you